- All right, y'all.
We're back, and I'm here with my friend
Trisha Yearwood, give it up for her.
(audience cheering)
So Treesha.
Treesha?
I'ma say your name forever
like that like Treesha!
- Yes, Kelly!
- Trisha likes to keep
it real, just like me.
And so it's time to find out
what she really would and wouldn't do.
...In certain situations
with a quick round
of Trisha Year-wood or wouldn't.
(Kelly singing)
You better yodel over there, I hear you.
- Look at that theme song for the game!
- Dang, you got your own
theme song for the show.
Okay, so I'm going to hit this button
and an awkward scenario
will appear on the screen.
Trisha and I will have
to say what we would
or wouldn't do in each case.
Are you ready?
- I'm so ready.
- Okay, here we go.
So you bring your dog to a friend's house,
and you find your dog by
the shoes at the entrance.
He's pooped in your friend's shoe.
You clean the poop, but would you,
or wouldn't you tell your friend?
Who doesn't tell your friend
that your dog (bleep) in your shoes?
- I mean, if they're your
friend, you have to say.
Plus I'm pretty sure,
if I cleaned your shoe,
you're still going to know.
- [Kelly] It's gonna be wet.
- It's like, "Trisha, why do
my shoes smell like poop?"
I would tell.
- [Kelly] I would tell.
I'll be like so there was this
time that you invited me over
and then my dog took a poo in your shoe.
- So, sorry about that.
- We're good friends.
- Okay, your best friend forever
needs you to move a body.
No questions asked.
Would you, or wouldn't you help?
I'm going to help you find
a really nice attorney.
(audience laughs)
I ain't going down.
- I don't believe that.
We're the same.
- If my sister called, I love you Alyssa,
but I would visit you every day in prison.
- I mean, my question really should be
"Would you help move a body again?"
But let's just move on
to the next question.
(everyone laughs)
- Would you do it again?
It was risky the first time.
- I'll never do that again.
- You got away with it the first time.
That's amazing.
You have your boss and her
family over for dinner,
your new puppy wanders in with a toy.
(Trisha and Kelly laughs)
- An adult toy.
- Would you, wouldn't you
admit what the toy was.
100%, I'd be all in.
- Oh, no.
I would just make up
something like ridiculous.
Oh, this is what's really special massager
that I just got that I
was told to be really good
for my shoulder that's
been giving me trouble.
I know it's bright purple, but...
- Let's spin again, shall we?
- [Trisha] I love this game!
You're in your office
and you think it's safe,
so you let it rip.
Just then, your coworker walks in.
Would you, or wouldn't you
be honest about the smell?
I'd totally own it.
- I'd probably totally own it.
- Yeah, I'd be like my bad.
Sorry!
- I don't know.
I might lie about it.
It just depends.
I might just pretend it didn't happen.
People do that too, though.
You just like, you know,
and then they're like, what?
And you're like, agh!
Just say you did that.
Like, come on.
- I love my kids.
I'm like, "Was that you?"
"Yep."
It's like ownership, they're proud of it.
I'm like, I need to calm this down.
You're gonna get made fun of.
- I can't smell right
now, so it's all good.
- See, you can't smell.
You're the greatest friend to have around.
- Except for, I also don't
know if I do something.
(Kelly laughs)
I'm brushing my teeth a lot.
I'm like, I don't know what
smells, I have no idea!
- [Kelly] Oh my god, that's amazing!
- [Trisha] This is so good.
- [Kelly] So fun!
- [Trisha] We need a therapist.
- [Kelly] Oh, I have one.
Your last French fry falls
between the seat in your car,
would you or wouldn't you
go fish for it and eat it?
- Yes, 100%.
- Here's the thing, I
wouldn't go for a French fry.
It's weird, I know I'm
Texan, I'm Southern,
I'm not like a huge French fry person.
But, if that was chocolate,
I would claw to get to it.
- How many of you guys have bought
a burger and fries and the fries fall over
in the car on the way
home into the floorboard.
You're going to get those
fries, that's happening.
- Yeah, once again, not with
that, but like with other food.
Involving chocolate.
- [Trisha] Yeah, so we're the same.
- Yup, yup, yup, yup.
- I would do it for a French fry.
- And that was Trisha Year-would
or wouldn't, everybody.
You're welcome.
It's wonderful to see you.
- It's great to see you.
Even from six feet away.
- I know.
You're you still, you, you probably smell.
I can't smell you.
You can't smell me now, that's great.
Look for the Trisha
Yearwood Pet Collection
everybody online and in stores right now.